i just want to scream about ordinary cat
i started watching this show
uh devon and ida came over we did the
patreon and i started watching this show
my big fat american gypsy
wedding i've become fascinated with
gypsies
and i think everyone should get a hobby
during quarantine i really do i think
you should get a hobby
do something better yourself i've chosen
gypsies
you can choose losing weight writing a
novel
i have chosen the romani people that is
what i wanna and
and listen to any of them listening
don't curse me
stop right there because i am afraid of
that i'm gonna talk about this very
respectfully
i don't want any of the curses i don't
think they run anything else so i don't
really have to worry about them denying
me
you know a spot on tournament of last
two
but i you know no if the curses are
legit none of that i don't want any of
it
there obviously the gypsies they've been
travelers forever
a lot of people think they're thieves i
don't
i don't i don't know about that i
who am i there you make a little
business here it doesn't work out you
get in the caravan to go to the next
town what about
hey i don't have anything to say about
that
but they love like gaudy over-the-top
uh dresses and bling and and
and and they have these weddings that
are wild and these women show up in
these
[ __ ] you know truly heinous
don't curse me heinous grotesque outfits
i mean
thing can we show screenshots
just google sandra chelli who's the
designer of these outfits this
this woman who's not a gypsy but makes
her living
selling these people uh dresses to wear
to weddings and i mean
dresses that like look at look at these
i mean i mean
you'd have to be on crack to walk down
an aisle in that
but they love it and they're and a lot
of them
marry like their first cousin a lot of
them do and
i'm fine with that i'm fine with that
don't curse me
i just want you to be happy and they're
very open about that i'm not saying now
is there then there's the charge if it
gets a little inbred if you're marrying
your first cousin
and and and hey i don't know i'm not a
doctor
but i i it's just such a great show it's
just such a phenomenal show
tlc just finds groups of people and just
everything on tlc is just you find
people whose lives have been destroyed
my 600 pound life my strange addiction
i mean tlc has a room of executives
basically going like let's find a [ __ ]
who's addicted to eating a couch
let's find somebody who's addicted to
eating glass
and it's destroying the lining of her
stomach and her esophagus
and let's put her on and let's put her
on camera
and then they found these small groups
of american gypsies
and they have weddings and they get
these feuds and they beat the [ __ ] out
of each other
and uh i just i you know i thought
somebody told me about this show and i
thought i'd watch it for like a few
minutes i ended up watching just
at least a youtube clip after youtube
clip after youtube but they are
fun they seem fun i don't know if
they're the brightest but they
seem fun people like they're
they're happier than anyone i know and
many of them
don't have much but they're happier than
anyone i know so
maybe they figured it out i don't know
i'm being very careful here
because i don't know if or i believe in
the curse or not do you believe in the
gypsy curse
you're a [ __ ] texas you come out of a
deeply conservative christian church you
believe in all this [ __ ]
i mean where do you stand at ken gypsies
curse people i think so
i'm superstitious aren't you like do you
do you see omens and stuff or like i
don't want to start problems here
that's all i'm trying to say a million
of them right 10 million gypsies i don't
know how many
there are of them i'm just saying
i respect your culture i want to get
this guy pat baby on the show
whose daughter priscilla is a
professional uh wrestler
i'm i the culture is fascinating to me i
don't love the dresses but i'm not
gonna get married in a wedding dress
so it's i mean these wedding dresses at
first
i mean when you look at them they're
horrific
they're almost scary let me find that
snow white one
yeah they're almost they're kind of
terrifying
and a lot of these weddings are in
fields
if you are a gypsy fan of the show
please reach out to me and let's start a
dialogue
about how i can kind of
understand and learn more about the
gypsy culture
yeah i mean look at that i mean it's
just it's
kind of oh it's a little disturbing it
lights up too at night it also lights up
yeah
but they love the bling and the
rhinestone i mean
so if you're a fan of the show and
you're a ramachal ramneshall gypsy i
don't really want the irish traveler
variety no offense
but i kind of want the real deal on the
show yeah
if you are a fan of the show and you're
on michelle gypsy
and that's possible
correct please respectfully
without cursing me
reach out because i'm just very
interested in the culture i just all i
want to watch is gypsies now
i mean it's crazy i just want to watch
gypsies
i just watch gypsy weddings gypsy balls
i don't i don't know what's happening to
me but i don't want to consume any other
content
at the moment except gypsies
there's something about it that i enjoy
i think of myself kind of like a
traveler
i'm a nomadic person to a degree am i
not
you are i've been persecuted throughout
history for being correct about
everything
why why do i not get to you know what i
mean
they're they're happy people they're
they're interesting people
are they inbred that's a that's a
fair question that i i am not
weighing in on in any way it's a
question that i am asking
because the for is if you marry your
first cousin what is that it's it's
incest
yeah but but you know let's not
come down on it hard too hard on the
show let's just
let it out as like uh i think chrissy
teigen's the real problem
and but you know i don't know it seems a
little
it seems a little sus
i don't have a hot first cousin
i can't relate um but there's a look
that a lot of these people have there is
a look
of that there's something going there's
maybe something a little off
not all of them haven't seen all of them
but certainly the ones on the show some
are pretty
uh no
not it's
in in unique there's an interesting
quality there
but i'm i'm actually just fascinated by
the culture
i've only seen the gypsies on the show i
don't know gypsies in real life
i'm not trying to discriminate against
them i i've i understand that all kinds
of people have all kinds of issues
out there i don't a cousin marriage is
not even in
any of in the top 100 problems in
america and it's not even a problem
do your thing um it's it's an
interesting culture the the
the dresses are a little strange
um and they beat they beat the [ __ ] out
of each other at a lot of these parties
like
because they don't like when the gypsy
marries the non-gypsy it's called the
gorger
so the non-gypsy is called the gorgeous
and then there's the gypsies
i don't know what it is i'm just saying
we're not going to talk about this for
the whole episode because i don't need i
don't need a [ __ ]
old woman coming over here and [ __ ] i
don't know
handing me a monkey's paw and cursing me
and maybe that doesn't happen i don't
know
but so here's what i will say if you are
gypsy and you want to like
you want to get involved with some
contact tracing call scams i would get
involved with you
i would fly to florida and set up a call
center right now with gypsies
with gypsies listen to call
people that and say that they've been
exposed to chronovirus and they get
their information
just throwing it out there but other
than that i will just continue to watch
every episode of this show the uk and
the american version that i can
because it is truly the only thing that
is making me happy i mean it's truly the
only thing is about i don't know why
watching
two women in brightly colored dresses
beat the [ __ ] out of each other in a
field
makes me happy but right now it is it's
hitting the spot
it's just hitting the goddamn spot we
all gotta find
moments of levity we all gotta find
things i'm enjoying
learning about different cultures isn't
that the point of life
learning about different cultures that's
what i'm doing on this show
that's why i watch my big fat american
gypsy wedding
to learn about different people and
their way of life
so if you're a romney shell gypsy not a
traveler i'm kidding if you're an irish
traveler
please message me on instagram and now
many of you
are going to lie because everyone always
lies when i say message me and they lie
and i know you lie and
i said are you in a secret society and
then you losers like yes i'm in skull
bones
we know you're not